he's now the head coach of uconn
football so it's great to have back here
on the rich eisen show the the great jim
mora how are you jim
rich
how about that huh i'm all the way back
here and uconn you used to hang out in
this area when you're at espn that's
right
yeah back to coaching ball which is what
i love to do and i tell you what i
couldn't be more excited about it yeah i
wanted to reach out to you and ask you
uh how this came about and why it came
about so let's let's let's go to the why
why do you want to you said you'd love
coaching ball and you missed it is that
basically assembly yeah you know rich i
i love
coaching football it's a passion it's
what i've done you know really my entire
adult life it's been as you know
what our family has been about my entire
life and um
i missed it i missed it a lot but i was
taking some time for myself and for my
family and my youngest son
trey
had kind of
asked me you know or talked about we
talked about
me not coaching until he went off to
college so that he wouldn't have to move
or i wouldn't have to move away from him
and uh
you know when you're a coach or and then
like a lot of professions your family
makes sacrifices for you and uh
my kids had moved around the country and
been uprooted and taken out of schools
and plopped in new environments really
to make new friends and uh
i had an opportunity really to take some
time and just focus on on my kids and
let them grow in the areas that they
were growing in and be around the
friends that they made and so i decided
to do that but trey went off to college
this year and all four of my kids got me
together and they said okay dad we know
you're passionate about coaching we know
you want to coach
it's time for you to go do it again and
uh
so this job came open and uh i had the
the
go ahead from my family and uh so i
reached out to them and we connected and
over the course of probably a month rich
we had
you know four or five zoom calls and my
interest continued to grow
i was over in italy last or a week and a
half ago and the athletic director david
benedict got a hold of me says listen i
want to come and see you in idaho i live
in sun valley idaho now
hike and fly fish and climb and mountain
bike and all those fun things and
when i got home from italy he was
already in idaho waiting for me and we
spent um
we spent six entire days together
talking about this job and
the challenge is you know it's they've
struggled i mean they've really really
struggled and uh
he put me on the phone with the governor
he put me on the phone with
a bunch of their supporters he put me on
the phone with business people with
alumni
with former players and to a person they
all just expressed amazing support
for this program and a real desire to
get it back on track and it just became
more and more inviting to me
i loved being at ucla i mean i loved it
i hated the fact that it ended because i
would have loved to been there forever
but it did and that's how it goes but
one of the things i thought when i
if i got a chance to get back in is i
wanted to be in a college town i wanted
to be where i could live right by campus
and at ucla i live 20 minutes away and
you know with traffic sometimes that
could be an hour hour and a half two
hours so i'm in a college town
it's a program that needs an infusion of
energy and passion and i think i can
provide that and i'm just
completely completely jacked up about
this opportunity so you're basically
you're breaking bread over the kneadery
up there in sun valley one of the best
spots on planet earth i've been there we
ran into each other in the neat room
that's true i know we have done
two years ago you and i ran into each
other it's a great it's a great spot
great mom and pop spot there uh in sun
valley idaho so he's putting you on the
phone with ned lamont here's what you're
saying did you chat with geno oriemma
too did you get nothing oh my god hey
rich yeah i went to dinner last night
with gino okay
yeah epic experience
epic you have you do you know gino
i don't know him no i've i've heard uh i
would love him okay you were back here
we got to go to dinner with gino all
right so i wish that i had had a a
microphone and a
recording device with me at dinner last
night
because he's the most down-to-earth
normal
guy but everything that comes out of his
his mouth first place got an amazing
command of the english language you know
and when i say that he's italian but i'm
not saying the way he talks i mean the
things he's able to talk about he's so
intellectual but he says it in a way
that makes so much sense
and it was like a lesson in coaching and
a lesson in life and i you know i want
to say hey you know whoa stop let me get
my phone out and record all these things
you're saying because
uh
when you spend the time with him like i
got to last night you realize why his
teams have been so great and you know
why he's won world champions
championships for our country and gold
medals for our country and 11 national
championships it's just
it was unbelievable rich you would have
been in heaven as well i was well i'm
sure red wine might have been involved
as well you know you know i'm going to
tell you that there was a little bit of
red water
and uh
he is a red we went to his restaurant he
has an italian restaurant here in
manchester so we went to his restaurant
we uh we had some great bread we had
amazing wine
we might have had a beer or two i think
he had a manhattan i think he likes
manhattan
we had some pasta and it was great this
is so cool so it's like it's you dan
hurley and geno now uh with the football
and basketball program so where do you
where do you see uconn football going
jim like what's the goal here like it
has to go up okay right now we're you
know we're
we're down a bit you know we're kind of
on the floor and and these kids what
i've been so impressed with and i've
been i've only been around him for a few
days i went to the clemson game
so i got to meet him a little bit um was
on the plane with him coming back here
so i'm getting to know him a little bit
but i'm absolutely amazed by their
character
their
enthusiasm i mean
they're fighting you know and they're
fighting for each other and they're
proud they hate to lose but they're not
walking around with their heads down i
haven't indicated i haven't seen any
indications of poor attitude which i
think is a real credit to the staff
that's here in lou spanos who's an
interim head coach
but it gives me like hope
because it's been a tough year you lose
your head coach early
you're not winning games um you're at a
basketball school basketball season's
starting everyone's excited about
basketball and you've got a couple games
left
and you know it'd be really easy to mail
it in and these guys aren't doing that
but
you know geno
and dan
they're higher on the totem pole they're
up i'm just way down at the base and i
got to try to work my way up and we've
got to work our team's way up and we
will jim moore here on the rich eisen
show is it fair to say you have
experience in coaching
football at a basketball school
yeah it is fair to say that is it fair
to say that jim ucla was a was a
basketball school and i think
i think we flipped it pretty quickly
there for a while and uh
you know listen it doesn't matter to me
if it's a football school or it's a
basketball school as long as the
students come out and support and we
give them something to support we have
to put a product on the field that's
exciting to watch that you know
gives them a reason to come in the
stadium and we're going to work hard to
do that but
i'll tell you i went so
i know you like all sports
i went to uh the women's basketball game
uh sunday we played arkansas
and paige becker who is the she was the
player of the year last year as a true
freshman
was oh my gosh
she put up 34 you didn't even know oh
jim i'd go smooth i'll never forget when
i first got to espn and i moved there uh
for the first time and i walked into a
sports bar one night and the place was
packed it was because they were watching
the the yukon uh huskies with gino
cochin and i think it was rebecca lobo
at the time and it's it's it is just an
absolutely
complete circus whenever the women take
the floor for for hoops in that
in that state but the reason why i asked
that question was kind of to lead to the
concept that your your successor at ucla
and chip kelly who you know built a
behemoth up in oregon he's he's not
winning at all i mean the the la times
just savaged him uh basically saying
that he's like stealing money here is
literally the phrase that they use is
there
is there is it difficult to win
football games at ucla do you think jim
the builder well rich yes i won my fair
share you did i know that
i know so
was it difficult yeah it's always
difficult to win but
you know we
we were 40 i was
i say i but we were 46 and 30 and that
included one bad year we only had one
bad year we went to five bowl games in
six years
so yeah it was a challenge it wasn't
hard it was fun i enjoyed it i was proud
of what we did there i was sorry that it
ended and i was sorry that it ended the
way that it did if life had gone the way
i planned it at that time
you know i would have stayed there until
my career was over and you know
hopefully had some kind of legacy but
that's not the way it happened and now
i'm just fortunate
david benedict the ad here is an amazing
guy i mean he's a star
and people are going to hear about him
if they haven't but uh
i'm just fortunate to have this chance
at uconn i'm fortunate to be around like
i said david
danny i'm i'm obviously geno i mean
they've got you know when you're on a
college campus rich it's awesome because
there's a whole bunch of great coaches
you can learn from
when i was at ucla
valerie fields valerie condos fields who
was the women's gymnastics coach and in
the hall of fame
i pick her brain corey close women's
basketball coach i pick her bling her
brain
um you know kellyannoy perez who's the
women's softball coach they win national
championships i pick her brain
and and adam the the i mean water pole
i'm talking to the water polo coach
about you know
football stuff or coaching stuff and
now i get that opportunity again on this
campus with not only those two i
mentioned but with a whole bunch of
other coaches that are really prominent
so
man i'm just lucky i'm just i'm really
fortunate that things have aligned the
way they have and i get this chance
because it doesn't happen to everybody
and i'm not going to let it
i'm not going to let it pass i'm going
to give it my all okay so we're going to
see how how's your folks how they doing
they are awesome and my dad you know
laughed when this whole thing was to
come together you know he was he has a
million ideas from for me and he said
that he will be at the big house next
year when we play michigan and he wants
to make sure you're there okay did you
know that yukon goes to the big house
you're breaking news to me i'm i'm a
little bit focused on the here and now
um
so i am too but i just i'm just looking
into the future yes and i'm seeing eisen
versus maura
i think it's next september 17th okay
and uh i'd like to invite you right now
to come down and and uh
be on our sideline with yukon gear on
i you know how i feel about you and you
know how i feel about your family
there's another gym in my life um
and did you see the guy that wears the
khaki pants and the yeah yeah
whatever he wants glasses no well uh bo
bow glasses um and that's right the bow
glasses yes no it's okay i don't want
you to get in trouble going to the big
house um and and you know the skinny m
the the bow the bow lid too um we're
gonna have to just leave
you know that there um
i love it though so so jim scene you're
having a great year your dad
please i mean i'm just it just it gets
me all the the gaming against michigan
state uh was uh was difficult uh towards
the end but they it's all set up it's
all set up for them to potentially still
uh beat ohio state and get to the big
ten championship so on and so forth but
um but your dad's planning on being an
issue though hadn't beaten ohio
yeah jim it's been an issue
no you know i know you've been out of
college football for four years jim so i
gotta tell you something is that you
know when there was all that kind of
talk last year about coach harbaugh jim
and shitty stay shitty lee should they
you know find someone else
i was so happy they stuck with him and
i'm so happy that after they stuck with
him he's like kind of he's kind of shut
everybody up
you know with the team that the way they
played this year and
listen i can't pick michigan or ohio
state because you know you get in
trouble one way or the other i hope you
know for your sake thank you jim a good
game
you know i i mean we all know what kind
of ball coach jim harbaugh is he's a
great one i appreciate you saying that
and uh i know look so so your dad's
gonna be at the big house so again is he
still is he still locked in on movies is
he still locked in on movies your dad
who is my favorite uh sex okay and why
yeah we gotta you need to get that going
he loves that stuff okay so he was
telling me stories the other day yeah
you probably know this when he was a kid
his dad was uh working for a fox studio
he was like
lighting guy for like humphrey bogart
and
i mean all these names he was throwing
out i was like dad i never knew that and
this was just like a few weeks ago he
told me this and all the
elvis presley came into this
talk to him one time you know all these
guys he's got a little history but yeah
he's he's seen them all i love him all
the movies he's up on it uh
i'm getting daily advice from him and
you know what was really funny one of
the first pieces of advice jimmy gary
jimmy jeremy listen i've been thinking
about it
you need to be nice to the media
i was never nice to the media
they were my friends i'm like dad i know
i got it i am nice with the media i'm
part of the media man i am i'm nice to
him and you know and
he gives me one the other day he says uh
he goes yeah
this is before i took the job i've been
thinking about this
i've given a lot of thought and i go
yeah and he just
you got to take this job they offer you
got to take this job you're you're an
effing competitor
guys like us we're built different we
got a cookie
and i'm like i got you dad and then he
calls me he goes dad he goes jimmy you
know you have the third youngest roster
in college football i go yeah dad i do
he goes no no no no no you know you have
the third youngest roster i'm like dad i
got you pal you know
so he's passionate about it it's pretty
awesome i mean it's
it's such a great feeling to have him as
a resource and have his support and and
he keeps me in line he keeps me in check
and it's great i love it and because he
didn't say effing you're just cleaning
it up for this studio
right here
yeah he said you know okay
lot right but when he does you know it's
you know he's serious
well indianapolis media knows that so
hey how about this
it's the 20th anniversary
of playoffs this year oh
you know who uh loves talking about that
because he's the one who beat the colts
that day
is mooch
yeah
coordinator that's right
that's right that's one of the best
parts of the story is that the playoffs
rant is because the niners beat the crap
out of the colts and you were the
defensive coordinator we had like we
intercepted peyton like four times
and how about this how about mooch this
is mooch i actually talked to mooch
yesterday he's my guy i love him he's
our guy too yeah
we go in after the game and i've just
beat you know we just beat my dad's team
which you know
it was great to win but it wasn't fun to
beat your dad of course and mooch gives
me the damn game ball
like we go back to the coach's locker
room and i go hey mooch i don't want
this damn thing that's my dad over there
and then of course dr york made me pay
for the game ball
oh
my god so you're right about that
i don't i don't want this thing man
jim you're right yeah picked off peyton
manning four times
um
40 to 21 absolute beat down playoffs
you talk about playoffs
oh rich i gotta pump him right now
please so my dad as you know has hated
that forever right
that he's remembered for that he just
got on cameo
oh gosh and he's doing he's doing his
playoffs thing for people so he's like
his little intro on cameo is like you
know it's uh ex coach jim mora
you know i'm on cameo and if you need me
to talk to your team your corporation
maybe help you get to like i don't know
like the playoffs
give me a shout so he's on cameo
crazy oh
he's all doing cameo you're he's on
cameo and you're at uconn that is just a
world's upside down it is that but it's
a great world thanks for the call jim
let's let's stay in touch man this is
just a blast a lot of laughs
right back at you that's a yukon
new football coach uconn huskies
football coach at uconn coach moore he's
even updated his twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show that
was fun hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here